[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez froid est-ce que
vous avez chaud et bien moi je vais
tiède tout va bien très bien vous êtes
prêts
c'est le warm up
[Musique]
pjanic oui j'ai eu quelques tweets
n'hésitez pas à réagir l'émission
hashtag slt la semaine dernière j'ai eu
un petit souci de chemises voilà comment
on peut voir peut-être en photo à l'ail
et quelques marques de repassage et
hervé nous dit le fer à repasser et en
panne voilà tout ça pour dire thierry
teisseire t'emmerder à trouver des
bonnes vannes et puis les gens veulent
juste savoir comment tu es habillée
c'est vraiment pas si twitter est juste
et puis des fois il ya des tweets
inutile et puis il y en a des très très
inutiles comme it's me qui dit ma télé
sont toutes les deux minutes ça me gave
on s'en bat les couilles voilà c'est pas
notre problème et puis pour terminer la
semaine dernière c'est francky vincent
aussi québécois de louper un oui et on a
déjà hâte sur twitter qui dit alors
c'est pas le mec qui fait du à bienne be
à saint denis un
jawad qui nous dit salut les terriens
indices ont réduit la guadeloupe à punch
sieste et pôle emploi ont été sur sur
ces terribles ex que six agrès le
deuxième degré se perd absolument est
juste voudrais conclure parce que là il
ya quinze jours n'est pas le seul à
il ya quinze jours on a fait un débat
sur l'islam qui veillait et yassine
belattar le lendemain vous a un peu
insulté sur facebook du coup vous
l'avais invité la semaine dernière il ya
quinze jours vous receviez des insultes
par texto et vous avez révélé que
c'était bruno masure l'auteur ces textos
et là vous allez l'invité ce soir donc
en fait pour être invité ici faut juste
vous insulter c'est sale
ça ratisse de [ __ ] je reviens la semaine
prochaine
non
juste tiré parce qu'on a un petit souci
on a des invités qui sont bien élevés ce
soir donc vous ne l'avez pas insulter
pour pour venir en revanche pour rester
il va falloir l'insulté je vais
distribuer des petites cartes non voilà
vous n'avez qu'à lire prenez soin de
chacun hop merci beaucoup
merci alors allez-y à tour de rôle on
commence à rire habitants
comment tu vas petite catin
mais ça c'est un compliment ça ouais
manon chien de la casse
moi j'ai eu tu n'es qu'une grosse
[ __ ] tiens c'est bruno masure à ses
mauvaises habitudes ils disent à ahvaz y
vieille bit
qui marche toujours
sacamerd mais c'est que de la chance un
sac à merde c'est terrible et donnant de
tracer un compliment
et j'accueille des champions
là
alors le bisou le bisou
[Applaudissements]
latine rue là là
mais du coup je range vous rend votre
fils
vous verrez
alors bruno bien ce qui se passe je
t'écoute alors j'ai hésité à répondre à
cette aimable invitation parce que
justement le côté embrassons nous
folleville sa cote est un petit peu
hypocrite est un peu un peu ridicule
même si ça peut être sincère donc si je
suis minute pour donner à l'antenne ton
numéro le 06 75 87 j'arrive pas à me
relire et gesca bible était
alors celle de seconde si je suis venu
ici vraiment très sincèrement c'est
parce que je voulais adresser un
formidable clin d'oeil à mon habit
baffie qui a servi un peu de go-between
de casques bleus et je voulais juste
dire que c'est un milieu le paf où il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'emplois mais il ya
beaucoup de jallet dire planches
pourries c'est plus élégant un milieu
dans tulle et voilà
et dénonce et je voulais voilà il
voulait dire juste sincèrement à tous
les téléspectateurs que non seulement
c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement drôle mais
c'est vraiment une très belle personne
dans son coeur il va naturellement
exemple
voilà la seule émission le gars 10,4 x
[ __ ] et dit c'est une très belle
personne
formidable bon alors donc tu es là mais
je suis content que tu sois là et tu
sais si tu étais venue dans l'émission
parce que tu t'es plein ne pas avoir été
invités car si tu étais venue dans
l'émission tu aurais eu trois quatre
minutes pour nous vendre ton livre pas
plus a donc vas-y vanhoutte on livre
alors ça s'appelle élise academy et dans
mon cerveau un peu fatigué j'imagine que
notre bon président hollande
décide de supprimer l'élection
présidentielle d'abord parce que ça
coûte très très cher quand on fait le
total ça coûte environ 300 millions de
francs compris les leurs au pardon moi
je compte entre ont osé et en ancien
français
et les législatives où seize mille écus
il réussit à persuader les uns après les
autres tous les leaders politiques de se
prêter au jeu et donc les candidats ils
sont onze comme comme les vrais mais pas
exactement ceux qui sont en lice
maintenant se retrouve dans une sorte de
loft diffusée par tf1 et ils sont sous
l'oeil des caméras pendant quasiment 24
heures et ils discutent ils mangent
ensemble etc ils s'engueulent ils se
renvoient les insultes qui se sont
lancés les uns aux autres et puis les
soldats à la salle et les
téléspectateurs votent de chez eux à
partir de leur téléphone c'est à campbon
pays on y arrivera à bon prix c'est
comme ça que ça va se terminer là sauf
qu'à un moment ça tourne mal le public
se désintéresse complètement dans
l'histoire et qu'est ce qui se passe à
ce moment là bruno avait faut pas
raconter la fin voilà lâché d'une
teasing lâcheté des cliffhangers
ce que je veux dire c'est que je mets
dans la bouche de zola de mes
données candidats ce qu'ils savent ce
qu'ils ont vraiment dit les uns sur les
autres ce serait pas drôle de d'inventer
quoi parce que on partirait dans un
délire à mon avis n'aurait pas grande
chance tandis que là je leur fait dire
exactement ce qu'ils ont dit les uns des
autres et des parents il ya des trucs
formidables qu'on peut pas inventer par
brigitte macron a dit un jour les
journalistes lui disais mais pourquoi
votre mari n'attendent pas 5 ans 10 ans
il est tout jeune il a tout le temps de
se présenter c'est là ça sera mieux dans
cinq ans et elle elle a répondu moi je
trouve ça formidable elle a répondu non
on ne peut pas attendre 2022 parce qu'à
ce moment là c'est ma gueule qui posera
problème à la gueule c'est génial elle a
vraiment dit ça beaucoup d'autodérision
pas ce matin en bouquin je faire un truc
comme à l'époque
[Applaudissements]
bruno masure et the academy
mais
les choses sont réglées
bruno masure merci les moyens avec nous
c'était de voir enfin un seul le terrain
[Musique]
là
le temps
[Musique]
salut les terriens solitaire la vie dans
votre tour du samedi soir bonsoir très
heureux de mon choix est sûre si vous le
savez désormais pour mission et daffy
taper
avec lui ce soir cinq cas rien de choix
juliette binoche
pendant academy award winner juliette
binoche mercredi vous serait la fiche de
deux films telle mère telle fille une
comédie française vous fait marrer et
ghost in the shell un film de science
fiction américain vous êtes bien payé on
va surtout parler du problème
autres terriens invité ce soir loeb qui
a réussi à faire porter des jupes aux
hommes rien pour garder ce qui est sous
jean paul gaultier
kerbala
[Applaudissements]
si ce soir tous les deux pour dans
l'intervalle un film dans lequel vous
jouez deux étudiants recrutés pour
transporter de la drogue entre amsterdam
et paris que juste vous demandez vous en
reste un peu ouais j'avais amené thierry
tagheer s'y tenir ses nerfs
[Applaudissements]
et ary abittan
ah et la [ __ ] de camair comment ça me
fait plaisir de voir la vérité
pourquoi je parle comme ça chapeau bas
qu'est ce que c'est limite raciste mais
c'est sympa
tu fais ça à tout le monde comme effet
ou qu'à moi non je crois que il n'ya que
toi y'a qu'à moi ouais alors s'essaya
cadre il va te falloir des tweets
tiédeur
différents invités insulté moi
a fait 4 à tréguier en 2017
nous accueillerons votre carrière du
samedi soir nicolas fraises l'homme qui
peut sortir de son corps
non
[Musique]
en témoignage exceptionnel le mec sort
de son corps et s'est prouvé voilà
l'émission s'appelle salut les terriens
le bout mais vraiment sortie au stade
c'est la saleté
[Musique]
et maintenant voici comme il a mon cdd
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon alors jugé la licra holding pour la
faire avec ary abittan il envoie
quelques maladresses
on dit à chaque fois deux
voies la soirée extraordinaire yann
l'oscar il ya de la légion d'honneur
franchement je vous lis on se voit au
musée grévin d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je
préviens le public tout de suite à la
pause pendant les pubs où je t'ai pas
tous en même temps l'autographe est à 10
euros le sel fille à 15 et le bisou à 30
euros
sam et l'a4
notre premier invité c'est l'une de nos
meilleures actrices françaises voilà et
en plus elle a eu tous les prix elle a
un peu au cinéma ce que serena williams
et au tennis mais sans les grosses
cuisses c'est juliette
[Applaudissements]
à juliette pour ses incroyables elle
peut tout faire sans forcer on dirait
pénélope fillon
l'a vu jouer dans le film telle mère
telle fille dans le film juliette vous
tomber enceintes en même temps que votre
fille ouais alors bien entendu c'est une
comédie un bond dans le nord c'est un
jour comme un autre mais
dans le film ou tombée enceinte à plus
de 45 ans et qui qui vous a coaché alors
c'est monica bellucci ou c'est rachida
dati non c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
notre deuxième invité thierry c'est
l'idole des jeunes des jeunes de moins
de 80 ans qui habite à neuilly-sur-seine
c'est jean paul gaultier
[Applaudissements]
jean paul gaultier qui comme emile louis
exigeant revoilà n'a que des prénoms
mais il n'a pas fait faites entrer
l'accusé et
non jean paul jean paul gaultier c'est
l'homme qui a mis des cônes sur les
seins de madonna aussi on le faisait
aujourd'hui ça serait des genouillères
mais
non je
franchirai plein ménage être le fait de
l'invité dommage jean-paul il a fait
défiler dita von teese à billets loana
maigre et nabila non coupable et puis la
ville et les plus grandes stars
mondiales lady gaga mylène farmer
madonna rihanna est aussi yvette horner
ouais voilà et oui mais non c'est pas un
hoax et des rires à l'époque yvette
horner pour les plus jeunes qui nous
regardent c'est un peu la fille de
claudio capéo et de larusso voilà ça
leur amènerait corner du coup vous
l'avait dessiné des détenus crois que
j'aurais en bleu blanc rouge j'en ai
récupéré une c vous savez la tour eiffel
voilà on vous étiez pas en forme ce jour
là mais on dirait une mascotte pour les
jo de paris mais
notre troisième à l'éviter il a le nom
d'une police d'écriture world apprête à
minuit roman comic sans ms voci ary
abittan mesdames
[Applaudissements]
avis harris et footing et parce que plus
il vieillit plus il se bonifie c'est un
peu comme george clooney lui ressemble
un peu non mais c'est vrai c'est fou on
dirait un char ordonné de casablanca
quand tu arrière on est parti d'un
boulaouane on va finir sur un
saint-émilion assez extraordinaire
double actualité thierry pour harry un
spectacle qui s'appelle my story voilà
on peut voir la fiche qu'est ce qui
s'est passé derrière et ce qu'on dirait
la fin d'une vidéo jackie et michel mais
avec les télétubbies c'est tjs crois que
j'ai retrouvé les coupables regardez qui
c'est soit que céline
collin
[Applaudissements]
et puis y'a pas que la signale cinéma
pour harry aussi après qu'est ce qu'on a
fait au bon dieu avec christian clavier
les visiteurs 3 et christian clavier
voici à bras ouverts et christian
clavier c'est une carrière ou une
filature
et puis pour terminer notre dernière
l'itc le seul qui a été content
l'élection de donald trump parce que
comme ça on fait plus chez sur sa coupe
de cheveux c'est probable
[Applaudissements]
clem adams qui est venu avec
mademoiselle bonsoir anne manon
parti comme ça vous vous êtes tous les
deux dans gangster dames c'est un très
bon film le pitch très rapide ces trois
jeunes un peu bidon qui se retrouve à
devoir aller chercher de la drogue ou
aux pays bas c'est un peu mon biopic
avec thierry non c'est fou cette passion
qu'ont les jeunes pour amsterdam parce
qu'en vrai amsterdam tu retires la
drogue et les [ __ ] c'est poitiers c'est
pas que c'est un très bon titre de film
ce que c'est des gangsters à amsterdam
donc ça donne gangster dame heureusement
que c'est pas des gangsters à bangkok
simon ça donne dans bangkok et
a enfin expliqué d'abord non non on
n'explique pas appuyé
[Musique]
tasha
un jardin j'ai mis en vente
tu côtoies
[Musique]
je dois l'avouer
hommage hommage à mes wayne hommage à
police et hommage à joey starr vécu je
me suis aussi réconcilier le nombre de
gens avec qui je n'aurais on vient de se
réconcilier avec gad grâce à toi et oui
c'est génial ça c'est une très belle
édition avec des gens à qui tu t'es
disputer oui c'est un con mais par
contre ce sera le téléthon c'est
bonne émission merci mon petit
et on passe maintenant à notre
territoire neuf semaines
madame ce rebond soit alors mais bien
d'accord le tai chi toi tu pour nous
évidemment c'est pas pour quelle adams
vous partager tous les deux la fiche
donc de gangsters dame le nouveau film
de romain lévy après radio stamm avec
patrick timsit manu payet et comme levin
ouais jusqu'ici manon c'est avec
jean-pascal de l'astarac que vous
partagiez la fiche de section à la de
recherches sur tf1 jean pascal c'est le
mec à pécho jennifer est vrai qu'au
début ouais ouais il avait fait que je
suis un nazi d'acteurs 1
alors maintenant ça n'a pas dû être
facile d'embrasser l'idole de vos neuf
ans parce que regardiez genre parce qu'à
la télévision
une fois c'est une fois
votre amoureux il a pris comme on se
tutoie la batterie jean pascal a mal
pris le général
basbug alors avant ça depuis l'âge de 5
ans vous faisiez du doublage ouais comme
votre maman vous avez doublé emma watson
dans harry potter j'ai la voix française
de hermione granger ouais ouais
je sais faire moi aussi
tu sais quoi tu finiras chauffeur de
salle
[Applaudissements]
alors
ya eu six grecs j'adore alors qu'ils
s'appellent en pas s'empêcher ouais
on regarde à quoi ça ressemble sauvages
qui font
boum ce qui ne nous regardait comme une
merde en plus avec sa source dans les
sourcils et sa salade dans les buts el
fasi a commencé à piquer et je lui dis
toi tu fermes ta gueule ok je te sors de
suite je te frappe devant tout le monde
vasiliev ça va être dur avec mon frère
après je la sors de la défonce devant
toutes ses copines les grosses manga et
pick up sont bâtis y avait des vidéos de
la tête qui tournait ce que j'ai pu j'ai
plus celle à qui il partageait ma vie à
mon frère donc tu es comme qui dirait
cependant un peu dans le célibat
je m'en bats les couilles mec chatter en
direct
8 à 8 à l'époque
alors ce qu'il faut dire quand même
c'est que ses co réalisé par julien
hollande le fils du président de la
république comme un savez c'est comme
quand on sait que le fils de sarkozy et
les rappeurs on se dit quand même que ya
pas de doute ils veulent tuer le père
des enfants
mais c'est fou parce que je pensais que
j'étais la seule à le savoir fallait pas
le dire
dix ans c'est une habitude à prendre je
te le dis alors votre amoureux appris
comment l'histoire du god ce qu'il est
gros l'aude et l'hérault sami zaoui il a
bien pris ah ouais ça c'est ben ouais ça
se passe
[Musique]
quitter c'est sûrement
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'elle les gens l'appellent
l'idole des jeunes il en est même qui
l'envient faut dire qu'il a quand même
fait 12 millions de chiffre d'affaires
sur scène en 2016 12 millions d'euros
mais là messieurs et 18 millions de
spectateurs au cinéma jusqu'à
aujourd'hui tu sais quoi
[Musique]
ouais je suis comme ça d'accord d'accord
fillon j'ai flippé dit ya tellement de
choses sur ce plateau
un triomphe place et je suis très bien
sûr je suis très heureux très fier et ça
fait s'affaisser john callas a fait sept
ans mais il ya déjà plein de choses
c'est ce que tu as quelque chose à quoi
tu as 25 berges corps à corps mais
j'imagine le mec le pognon
alors comme gad elmaleh vous tentez kev
adams la lente l'an américaine mais
cette fois pendu au chacun pour sa
gueule à l'américaine là c'est vraiment
personne n'y croit tous les coups sont
permis là si c'est quoi c'est justement
parce que personne n'y croit qu'il faut
le faire alors ça va se passer comment
avec garde vous près la côte ouest et
lui la côte est donc en jeu non mais en
tout cas on s'entend toujours très bien
et c'était un dieu sur cette formidable
et moi j'ai beaucoup appris à ses côtés
et voilà il fallait heureux je suis très
heureux de
la casse couille alors mis en ligne le
léger c'est oui j'ai régressé à côté
nord le mois il m'a dit papa laurent
baffie c'est marrant tu vois comme quand
il dit des choses différentes alors
profité d'être la caf parce que juliette
peux vous donner des conseils pour
gagner un oscar et jean-paul pour voir
les sommes madonna c'est vrai que je
porte du jean paul gaultier tous les
jours ah ah ouais ouais et quand je vais
en boîte les siennes fond voilà boîtier
le parfum du parc huawei oui je pars pas
le monsieur sur mes épaules
bon et puis à ces normes il ya bollywood
nous
vous avez tourné un film à bollywood oui
oui effectivement à la fin de l'année ça
m'intéresse beaucoup j'ai été en inde
j'ai trouvé ce pays extraordinaire et
donc voilà je fais un film avec un
metteur en scène qui s'appelle vicas
balle à la fin de l'année l'oréal a fait
un film qui s'appelle quinn qui a été
très remarquée la barre en inde et dont
je suis très excité alors est-ce que
vous avez plus peur du du scénario la
touriste a la base je
génie peur de l'art ni peur de l'autre
des très bons scénaristes et
contrairement à ce qu'on croit
évidemment c'est un pays en
développement mais il ya tout ce qu'il
faut pour que n'ya tout le monde soit en
très bonne santé alors est ce que vous
avez commencé à prendre le indy oui il
faut que je parle hindi dans le film
donc effectivement je vais je verrai ce
que vous savez dit pas
non plus c'est sûr elle n'a pas tenu
longtemps non kendam madame st gallen
dette à l'intérieur
je sais quoi je n'adore maire joël ou
biture et je t adore mais me demande pas
d'unité à sion en franchement j'ai passé
ça maintenant je suis un acteur le
mondial j'arrivais ici
l'a jamais fait
il ya un truc qui est encore plus
incroyable que tout ce qu'on vient de
dire c'est que vos textes sont étudiées
dans les écoles de profs ah ben on
savait pas ouais bah je ne savais pas si
on allait redoubler
zen extrait interview kev adams dire que
les profs apprennent leur métier à
partir de l'interview à
saisir
[Musique]
mélange des poissons
alors mercredi c'est la sortie de
gangsters dame un film qui marque un
tournant dans votre carrière puisque
après avoir joué les lycéens un peu
stupide pendant des années nous
interpréter un étudiant peu stupide un
gandhi on est
alors est ce que vous vous souvenez du
pitch où l'herbe est trop bonne et ouais
c'est l'histoire de ruben aucun étudiant
en droit qui effectivement tombe
amoureux de nora et on comprend pourquoi
et
effectivement il va découvrir qu'elle
est une dealeuse voilà et qu'elles
montrent chercher de la drogue à
amsterdam pour la ramener sur paris qu
elle en vend à la fac c'est exactement
ça bah oui je sais bien diriger j'ai
fait le film
alors comme dit romans bd réalisateur
que je salue les blaireaux vont devoir
devenir des héros c'est tout l'esprit du
film quoi c'est exactement ça c'est
exactement ça c'est l'histoire de deux
de nos deux personnages avec manon un
point a à un point b à la fin du film
salt est intéressant c'est pas que des
heureux y a pas de point gênant non mais
là un truc maintenant on sait que quand
il a lu le scénario le première version
du scénario il a demandé que ça soit
plus basé sur l'histoire d'amour quand
même ce vrai ou pas à la base c'était
trois gars ont fait savoir hier c'est
sur une idée de kiev qui alors pourquoi
pas une gonzesse parce qu'à la base
c'était écrit pour trois jeunes garçons
tête à 15 ans vidal m star va me
chercher de la drogue why not quand tu
es en études de droit et que tu es
intervint d'arrabal 1 h 1 moi j'y crois
moins il faut une vraie motivation
effectivement une meuf quelle meilleure
motivation qu une meuf tu vas n'importe
où pour la cie dont tu es amoureux tu
vois premier d'accord parce qu'après
quand il sera en aura que des infos
chaudes ils en profitent
[Applaudissements]
dans la vie soit tu gères la peau l'idée
c'est de la merde soit tu baltringue
je m'appelle ruben jablonsky et je ne
suis pas ce qu'on appelle un mec cool
baltringue la jetant un regard de femme
trompée noir et pas à l'aise avec les
jambes tu me chammas
oublié ton
ont croisé mon gt spyder ok donc là moi
j'ai passé de la drogue je viens d'avoir
un coup de coeur pour toi tu pars demain
matin stade accueillera tu me ramènes un
petit paquet mais je voudrais déjà vous
dire merci beaucoup pour cette
proposition d'emploi
du reste je suis mes ennuis c'est donc
sa hauteur d'homme
[Musique]
a l'air d'être une bonne ville de kaunas
et 6 juin prenez des vélos
compris ce qui compte c'est des hipsters
ça ne compte pas
[Musique]
n'ouvrez jamais le paquet
vous embête pas d'éloigner un petit peu
les chats puisque je crois je suis à la
route mais fait ce côté ça ira les
chiens en cas de contrôle
règle numéro 2 jamais de contacts avec
du liquide sinon la came les mornes et
sa toilette avec ses chars ses pas les
serviettes sales jeunes
vous passez s'inquiète-t-il et
l'accession oui c'est un escroc
ramène mon paquet
si tu veux pas être issu dick
ce qui compte dans la vie
ce qu'on sait faire c'est ce qu'on ne
sait pas encore d'elle
beaucoup
dans les habitations
[Applaudissements]
mason
alors qu aime chez drucker vous avez
tenu à préciser que certes amsterdam on
va fumer des herbes illégale et on va
voir défiler dans les vitrines mais vous
avez dit chez michel drucker c'est sympa
cinq minutes au bout d'un moment c'est
vite mal simple et
déjà chez truc déjà ici je vais disputer
faut adapter son discours face à toi
élan évidemment je vais vous dire que
c'est génial formidable et consorts la
spa mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
on est resté un mois amsterdam colonne
faire la grande sophie manon amsterdam
c'est très kiffant je trouve trois
quatre jours voilà un mois ouais quand
au bout d'un mois tu sors de l'hôtel ça
sent la beuh dans la rue tu vas sur le
plateau de tournage tu vois des meufs à
poil dans les vitrines pardonnez moi
d'avoir mon avis je trouve ça un peu
malsain tu maintiens ce que tu as dit je
suis au coeur d'une blague sarda vasile
blaga grâce à un mec qui va me servir et
wine filles sublimes derrière une
vitrine beauté insensé étape au cas où
il fait c'est combien et l'api 2010 et
500 euros nets fait c'est cher tu es la
fille fait oui mes cd double vitrage
[Applaudissements]
l'epa salle puisqu'il a rencontré la
femme de sa vie amsterdam parce que tout
le monde attend pour hong kong et la
radio la vitrine beaucoup non beaucoup
des filtres ceci dit j'ai appris
récemment dans la presse que je suis
avec miss univers oui j'ai fait cela je
savais pas c'est pas vrai tu savais pas
j'étais conférant géré au port ils
disent ils sont fous amoureux tout se
passe bien il vient d'acheter un truc
ensemble et tout d'un coup j'étais
content pour moi
mais se dit c'est cool
c'était là
[Musique]
pendant ce temps les terriens dont 121
sonne le retour sur terre toujours en
compagnie le jeu
dont jean paul gaultier aucun malade m
sari habitants de longue vie
et maintenant en l'honneur de donc
sernam on va faire un quiz sous
substances
[Musique]
j'aime bien si c'est vrai ou si c'est
pas vrai alors des policiers qui brûlent
trois tonnes de cannabis et drogues
toute une ville ça existe ou pas ce
serait très marrante bien moi je dis oui
c'est vrai je dirais que non amsterdam
ils ont pas besoin de brûler quoi que ce
soit déjà dans la ville alors c'est vrai
en fait
[Applaudissements]
c'était dans le parisien a tangué range
en indonésie la police a voulu se
débarrasser de trois tonnes de cannabis
saisies mais la fumée s'est propagée
dans toute la ville voit les yeux une
femme qui insiste pour faire goûter sa
cocaïne aux policiers ça existe ou pas
ouais ouais ça ça doit exister ouais
c'est source europe1 donc voulu savoir
si la cie les flics pourrait dépasser la
ligne
ça s'est passé à toulouse l'année
dernière un homme drogué qui ces
peluches lui même car ils pensent être
une orange ça c'est des légendes comme
ça peut arriver dans les quartiers scdc
des légendes qu'on entend souvent
j'avais entendu aussi un gars qui se
jette par la fenêtre parce qu'il pense
qu'il est un choc a piqué quand bahia un
bol j'ai entendu aussi celle là il avait
entendu peu après les chants qui fâchent
du coup je dirais que c'est chez passé
oui il a faim ouais heureusement qu'il a
pas faire une vidange
oui c'est possible bien évidemment débat
nous a tracé les légendes telles et
légendes urbaines les gens du web série
qui montre des jeunes sous acide qui se
donne pour défi de monter des meubles
ikea
je crois pas que ça existe mais il faut
le faire ah ouais j'en parle c'est le
bon âge pour moi j'avais pas besoin
d'être sous acide pour monter le mamiya
comme si tout est bien ça existe oui
c'est une chaîne youtube
[Applaudissements]
un homme qui troque sa copine pour
pouvoir jouer aux jeux vidéo n'assure
plus
un pays qu'ils n'égalisent plusieurs
drogues dures dont l'ecstasy la kétamine
et de crystal meth ça existe ou pas non
non eh bien ça existe en irlande le 10
mars 2015 la cour d'appel de dublin
jugent inconstitutionnelle une loi sur
les drogues installant un vide juridique
donc et pendant quelques jours toutes
les drogues étaient tolérés en irlande à
ces tests est vacant
depuis très très bas qui après avoir
pris de la drogue est devenu supérieur
mans
genia doc gynéco ray c'est ça qui est
drôle
je pense que je pense que c'est
absolument impossible c'était cet abruti
plus qu'autre chose ça peu de gym ubo si
ça peut aider désinhibée un mode 4 c'est
la procaine
[Applaudissements]
la vernière allaitantes un homme qui
sous l'emprise de la drogue des terres
son père sur wii c'est la fille d'yves
montand
et oui c'est tard dans le kentucky c'est
arrivé il a déterré son père a pourri la
plante et de labeur
[Musique]
et on passe maintenant à notre grand
d'invité d'honneur de la semaine
ça pourrait être toi mais c'est juliette
binoche
la star qu'on appelle juliette cinoche
ici en france absolument absolument
juliette binoche rebond soir j'étais à
ses lectrices à avoir gagné un césar un
bafta un oscar et un prix
d'interprétation à cannes à venise et à
berlin il vous reste plus qu'à ligue des
champions et l'aude d'or
[Musique]
lens car je
[Applaudissements]
l'oscar sécu pour le patient anglais
2001 et en fait il vous avez poussé à
bout dans une scène je vais pleurer en
fait c'est parce que c'est le dernier
moment avant de donner une note et
naziha au patient anglais et il y avait
de la musique avec back to le montant
qu'il y avait des branches de france
gall
il y avait un silence sacré est
magnifique et en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que j'ai ouvert l'an poule pour
jouer et je l' ai tellement ouverte
qu'elle m'a ouvert les doigts donc il y
avait du sang est vrai fêté un peu
horrifiée parce qu'il avait peur que je
me fasse mal et en fait j'ai j'ai perdu
le contrôle et j'ai un peu pleuré et je
pense que j'ai l'oscar à cause de serre
après un accident tout bête c'est vite
arrivé sur le sol
alors qu'il faut dire
c'est que lauren bacall côté contre vous
pour les oscars où il avait gagné une
espèce de sentiment d'imposture oublié
lui lui donner le ska en fait vous
l'avez donné à votre fils qui a joué
avec le ska et peu à peu lors ses
écailles et tu vas peut assez rapidement
la plaie est en fait il suffit de
gratter un peu et laure devient tout
simplement s'est ainsi bien sa red bull
mais voilà ce n'est pas de l'or massif
ont fait non les [ __ ] ils ont changé
quand même
c'est pas parce qu'il peut pas garder un
oscar pelé donc on leur en va de bart
weetjens car ne m'a pas changé il a
changé le regard des eaux c'est vrai
ouais ouais t'as regardé votre regard
cataractes
j'en avais fait du bien c'est une star à
hollywood quand elle a pas de café
l'appelle directement
la loose alors juliette pour toutes les
jeunes actrices qui nous regardent et
qui pourraient se sentir écrasé par
votre filmographie et par vaux
récompense je me suis dit qu'il était
important de regarder vos débuts à
l'écran parce que ça peut donner
[Musique]
moi
je la prends prenez un chamallow entre
le pouce et l'index affleck voulons
poser délicatement sur la langue
est là étendez vous voilà
prolonger le plaisir est en écoute à
chemin vous prenez un autre chamallow et
pour commencer au moment où bon qu'au
bon fond
alors juillet quand on trees mercredi au
cinéma dans le film telle mère telle
fille de noémie saglio avec elle en
heure en compétition en fait en gros
faut le dire mais moi j'aime bien l'idée
que les gens quand ils ont envie d'aller
voir un film façon ils vont aller ces
comptes comédie donc quand même
complètement une comédie très girly qui
est la vôtre est complètement une
comédie hyper trash qui est la nôtre et
et ça l'est certainement bien meilleur
mais je
[Applaudissements]
sais que j'en suis à toi ils sont le 5
avril tu es tranquille
ils sont 5 avril je vais rester dans la
flagornerie vous jouez la mer ou la
fille
j'ai cru que je suis en train de me suis
en train de me truquer les eaux
ap
et
alors le pitch le pic vous êtes une mère
qui vit aux crochets de sa fille qui est
enceinte et qui découvre qu'elle est
elle même enceinte à 50 ans après avoir
couché avec son ex mari alors vous êtes
donc une mer encore ado
envahissante et déjanté vous fait la
gueule quand on vous refuse quelque
chose vous rangez pas votre chambre vous
fumer de l'herbe vous baiser sans capote
alors votre fille camille cottin elle
c'est l'inversé les mariés salariés
organisé ça a rien à voir et le père
c'est lambert wilson que vous retrouvez
trente ans après rendez-nous de téchiné
c'est marrant à l'époque j'étais pas
bien connu mais là vous avez fait
connaissance ouais voilà parce que
j'étais assez fasciné par lui jeta
boroughs lui et donc j'ai pas osé lui
parler j'étais intimidé et là trente ans
après bon bah on a pu enfin parler
génial j'adore ça il est vraiment drôle
alors vous dites germinales ça me fait
plaisir de revenir en arrière de vivre
ces moments
d'adolescentes que je n'ai jamais eu
c'est vrai pas un que vous habitiez dans
le
enfance de juliette binoche dans le loir
et cher à mondoubleau
c'est vrai oui c'est pas loin de
bordeaux mais bon alors je vois les
chewing gum en tue comme moussavi de
butin
comment tu connu ça toi mes grands
parents étaient des doigts aux ongles
aux italiens aux mobylettes
et donc en sortons de cette adolescence
vous êtes fait une permanente blonde bah
ouais on avait tout à l'heure avec les
chamallows tout ça même si c'est ma
première maintenant tu es blonde blonde
annonce way et finalement ce rôle là
dans le film de sa bio c'est un peu une
permanente blonde non à banon
non-croyants mr ouai bah les perruques
ça existe à celle peru
peru dans notre film à nous de l'ami
occupée
ça devient bon alors on va regarder la
bande annonce vous allez abbaoui un bon
on y va
[Musique]
maman tu descends s'il te plaît tu vas
tomber là et un moment devient vraiment
les parents et les parents
vous êtes sa soeur non sa fille
elle est logé nourri blanchi
ce n'aurait même pas compte
elle est bourrée au nom oui moi on a
quelque chose à vous dire je suis
enceinte quand tu pars où vous avez pas
le garder
elle a toujours été très drôle quand est
ce que tu vas arrêter de me faire la
gueule des fils unique va être maman
qu'est ce qui te plaît beaucoup ça par
exemple
tu veux tout simplement un grand moment
pourquoi pas mimie bon ben on va boire
un verre
ce soir recoucher avec mon ex mari vingt
ans après pas vraiment non
j'ai ma mère voilà votre mère est
enceinte il quoi quoi
on s'attend même de français seraient
pas banal non vraiment c'est bravo ouais
je sais y'a pas de mots c'est peut-être
aussi mature ok c'est bon là je
l'appelle
j'étais en libye
c'est pas possible pas aussi bon ben si
si
tu peux pas réfléchir de temps en temps
pas quel âge je t'en veux pas parce que
tu vas avoir un enfant je t'en veux
d'être un enfant
el hammam adn
la vie vous laisse toujours le choix
d'en faire un accident
une aventure
et du coup la mère de mon petit fils
sera aussi la soeur de votre enfant voit
la
[Applaudissements]
première depuis 2005 mais il sait bien
j'ai très bien je semble pas d'avoir un
enfant je t'en veux d'être un enfant
très bonnes phrases
[Musique]
et mon père aussi maman si
l'émotion
[Applaudissements]
est maintenant là
la question la plus importante juliette
comment ça va question romeo soit pas
mal d'accord alors vous avez déclaré mon
rêve serait de réussir une vraie vie de
couple pour l'instant je ne suis pas
tout à fait arrivée c'est à dire que si
une personne du monde s'est parlé c'est
compliqué débit tooway
dans le divan de marc olivier fogiel
vous avait révélé en avril 2016 je suis
revenu avec quelqu'un d'antan et c'est
carrément génial c'est ça
je veux pas aller plus loin c'est
ambitieux basé sur la discrétion
ce serait quand même génial parce
qu'elle dit pas annexes elle dit
quelqu'un d'antan si vous êtes vraiment
j'adore le détail comment il s'appelle
vous êtes vraiment une actrice
romantique à quelqu'un dans le temps
c'est beau bon ce qui
donne en que je vous demande pas au
lecteur un acteur non c'est pas le genre
laurent clan ben je sais que c'est pas
le genre de la maison tu es juste un
avis
de ses initiales pour les gens qui je
mets moi je vais juger j'ai rencontré le
compagnon de juliette à los angeles
avant oui et alors il a tout balancé
je peux me permettre il m'a dit que
mercredi il allait voir gangstarr dames
c'est tout
juliette est ce que un jour un homme
vous a dit mais quelle lumière jaillit
par cette fenêtre voile à lorient et
juliette et le soleil
que shakespeare et ouais j'aime bien ça
m'a scotché à gmail ou non c'est pas moi
à tanger roméo et juliette est ce qu'un
homme vous a dit ça aussi bien écrit
j'ai pas sûr mais dans les yeux tous se
dit
julien du roi que le mieux maintenant ce
serait de faire une interview par amour
[Musique]
juliette binoche jusque paramo vous
seriez prête à arrêter le sim ouais
et la chance pépère
est-ce que par amour vous soyez prêt à
vous convertir à une autre religion
non non est-ce que par amour pourriez
quitter la france pour toujours et vous
exiler en syrie
un show les paras - vitré
sentirais très très mal est ce que par
amour pour y avoir recours à la
chirurgie esthétique
non
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête
le mec il adore les rubens à prendre 20
kg
est-ce que par amour c'est une hypothèse
évidemment tout ça c'est de la fiction
vous seriez prête à vivre à trois avec
sa maîtresse ah mais c'est étonnant
parce que moi j'ai une idée d'un film
comme ça à trois roues avec ouais bah
oui donc c'est le sujet m'intéresse
vraiment mais je le sens
où
j'ai fait du bruit c'est vrai ça vous
avez des saints qui font du bruit
vous seriez prête à vivre à trois avec
sa maîtresse
j'ai une copine qui vit avec deux hommes
et je pense que c'est vraiment moi c'est
en étant dans l'épreuve que on pourrait
que je pourrais le savoir mais sans être
en phase de l'épreuve de l'espace vert
alors toujours on est toujours assez pas
mourant par amour est ce que vous seriez
prête à aller tous les soirs dans des
clubs échangistes n'ont carrément pas à
302 alors
qu'une fois par semaine d'ailleurs même
pas une fois par mois et même pas par an
non ouais alors ça vous n'êtes pas que
l'abbé chance d'y aller ou pas de vraie
maman aussi alors est ce que vous seriez
prête à devenir son esclave sexuelle à
tous si tout est transformé par l'amour
c'est plus de l' esclavage sexuel
et maintenant la question dite question
clotilde courau parce que tout il court
avait répondu oui est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à embrasser cent fois
ses chaussettes sales ah oui alors oui
pas de problème pas de progrès
[Musique]
ary abittan rebond soir
calais ou
comment ça va ça vient ça j'ai de plus
en plus beau merci les danses et à l'eau
de javel que vous les lavez pas dû
toucher avant brosse les dents et une
blancheur c'est vrai il manque que la
rose 2 dans la zone ultra bright ouais
vas-y vas-y souris sourit tant pis en
pis merci bon nous sommes heureux et
flatté évidemment d'accueillir le césar
de la promo
sauf le roi 4e roanne apremont arrive
vous avez réussi à envoyer des gens
voient les visiteurs 3
alors qu'est ce qui est bien avec les
visiteurs 3 c'est comment on est sûr
qu'il aura pas de visiteurs 4
c'est quand même un grand avantage en
même temps faut pas vous relâcher quand
même parce que j'ai lu des trucs de vous
la le 24 février vous déclarez dans le
télégramme de brest les bretons ont le
rire juste
bon une semaine plus tard vous déclaré
dans un journal belge les belges ont le
rire juste
j'imagine que dans le parisien on va
avoir les parisiens réagissent vous
l'adapter à chaque fois non non je te le
dire une fois et puis bon et puis c'est
vrai en plus et puis tous les sens il
peut avoir plusieurs départements
français qui ont le rire juste là c'est
pas grave alors on passe à la promo
alors vous êtes ici pour un film qui
s'appelle à bras ouverts le nouveau film
de philippe de chauveron avec christian
clavier et elsa zylberstein ans le pitch
c'est l'histoire de christian clavier
figures médiatiques de gauche un peu bhl
qui se voient obligés d'accueillir chez
lui des roms dont vous êtes le chef de
famille en fait c'est l'histoire d'un
intellectuel de gauche hu est prise au
piège lors d'une émission télé obs et il
va être obligé d'acquérir une femme et
demi au défi voilà quelqu'un lui dit
bête à corne accueillir chez toi
banalement des robes hd si malin il ya
des moments qui sont vraiment drôles
quand vous chantez la belle histoire de
michel fugain c'est beau roman c'est une
belle histoire
ses romans ce jour d'aujourd'hui
mais il est sage en
[Applaudissements]
fait ils changent tout le temps parce
qu'il est il est dans son jardin ouais
donc et pour l'accueillir parce qu'ils
accueillent chez lui en fait et il
chante tous les jours une chanson il a
chanté aussi gérer voir les petits
femmes d'égal que l'aîné j'ai fait du
mal je compte un compte en coq est
content
et alors vous avez une gueule d'un
string je travaillais le personnage un
oui j'ai beaucoup d'evry rome en plus
les séries de miral vous avez travaillé
exactement un très bien renseignés
effectivement on a travaillé toujours
avec des acteurs rome avec swing et j'ai
dû apprendre vraiment le rhum j'ai dû
apprendre vraiment les dialogues et
c'est un rôle en or que mr philippe de
chauveron en ce moment on est en train
de tourner dans toute la france avec ce
film et c'est un bonheur parce que on
est avec la même équipe que le bon dieu
et il ya une bonne odeur quoi ouais
vraiment se présente bien regarder à
quoi ça ressemble
la france ne peut plus accueillir toute
la misère du monde la france que j'aime
c'est la france qui partage qui
accueillent à bras ouverts c'est à dire
le titre de mon dernier arrêté
l'enfumage pourquoi vous ne donnez pas
l'exemple prenez-en chez vous
écoutez c'est très simple si une famille
de roms et dans le besoin est la
bienvenue chez moi 2 allée des roses à
marnes-la-coquette
[Musique]
alors bras ouverts merci merci
accueillir non merci à ces 3 000
cd rom europe ah oui pas les cd-rom
[Musique]
et revenez chez vous
c'est là pour moi
walesa on sait que je pense
bonjour a sauvé trois bien dormi c'est
une chambre à air de cannes 12
s'est passé tradition gros bourgeois ria
prenez un apport dans la cuisine on peut
pas être plus ouvert que ça
[Musique]
chez moi c'est chez vous ce soir nous
sommes tous des roms nous vouloir
devenir bon france
c'est encore d'y toucher
ayrault d'autres
[Musique]
des gages aux gens paient pas
ils intègrent de vie peut-être même un
peu trop vite
qui soufflait en rafale ces qualités
maison babic les pavés grand place
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jouer à l'intellectuel de gauche pour
qu'ils surmontent la vie c'est d'être
une torture non
le réalisateur c'est philippe de
chauveron donc caf un blockbuster avec
qu'est ce qu'on a fait au bon dieu un
film qui a fait 12 millions d'entrées
notre oui sans dinosaures ce handicap et
sans paquebot qui coule un truc
formidable alors le message du film
c'est quand même les roms sont bien
relou et les intellectuels de gauche
sont des idéalistes bidon comme un non
pas du tout on annonce ce film c'est
c'est d'abord sur le choc des cultures
et puis s'il est très très bienveillant
que c'est l'écriture de philippe et très
bienveillant ben ouais on l'a vu avec le
bon dieu le seul but de ce film c'est de
distraire et de faire rire les gens
c'est tout voilà et maintenant si ça
peut changer le regard des roms dans la
rue pourquoi pas ne pas s'en faire mon
pare brise quand même
voir donc c'est le 5 avril dans un
cinéma pression' et
et puis vous êtes en tournée vous êtes
en tournée dans toute la france avec
votre spectacle ary abittan l'homme qui
murmurait à l'oreille des merguez
non c'est my story alors j'imagine que
dans ce spectacle vous parlez de votre
maman énormément
non
vous dites aimer à couper la viande
jusqu'à l'âge de 10 ans
et elle me monter sur la taz avait sept
ans un slip rouge comme ça et je devais
chanter cette chanson on a été des
meubles happillon oui tout le monde et
noeud papillon et y avait la famille
habitant c'est simple c'est presque
cousin 17 cousine 23 tonton 13 face à
une grand mère et deux personnes c'est
pas qui c'est
et la grand-mère elle ressemblait un peu
à elie kakou madame sarfati ouais en
fait ça vous a beaucoup inspiré sa
énormément quand je voyais elie kakou
faire des sketches sur sa grand mère sur
sa tante j'ai dit mais on a le droit de
faire ça à la télévision ouais c'est ça
que j'ai envie de faire mais voilà
c'était quelqu'un d'extraordinaire
[Musique]
on va vous raconter dans ce spectacle
votre boulot le chauffeur de taxi pour
payer vos cours de théâtre oui c'est
exactement comme ça que molière a
commencé
qu'elle à l'incinérateur
rencontrés voilà ce qu'il a pu le faire
c'était on se retrouve
[Musique]
or à mon sens les terriens bonsoir les
terriens nous sommes de retour sur terre
toujours en compagnie de juliette
binoche
jean paul gaultier tahri du temps et de
la vie
et maintenant on passe à neutre tu es au
top du top de la semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean paul ii tire mon soir
jean-paul chanteuse mazel tov et pour
jean paul sont entrés ce matin
mais aujourd'hui
là
symbole dossier nucléaire en pleine
forme pour quelqu'un qui est exposée
dans les musées
c'est vrai que quand on est dans les
musées ça fout un coup de voilà eh ben
vous êtes malgré tout en très grande
forme
[Musique]
si tu es fort bravo jean paul
or selon un sondage bébé à notre maître
publié en février
la grotte dans les cheveux ni pardon
ça passe à l'image après pour lui et
parce qu'à chaque fois il me propose
d'aider des pitchs de film est touchant
dans ses films mais je vais proposer un
rôle de robben n'a pas voulu aller jouer
dans le clip est à
propos d'un film qui coûte pas bien j'ai
un pij de films pour toi de folie ces
deux buts ils sont dans une voiture et
roulé roulé roulé roulé roulé roulé
roulé roulé roulé rôle ils arrivent au
péage et après tu fais ce que tu veux
alors jean paul gaultier donc selon un
sondage bva publié en février vous êtes
le couturier préféré des français vous
savez ça
internet est un garçon d'une gentillesse
dont simplicité limite crétins
vous êtes la dernière fierté de la
france
avec le porte avions charles de gaulle
audio via les le ménage à trois
c'est plus drôle alors fin janvier avait
triomphé lors de la fashion week de
paris avec un défilé qui a bluffé tout
le monde on regarde à quoi ça
[Musique]
oui
ça
non
[Musique]
la prochaine fois à la fin je viendrai
avec un déambulateur jeu ouais alors
c'est qu'eric la fashion week parce que
c'est impossible de trouver de la drogue
à des prix décents
je te jure c'est là contrairement à
d'autres créateurs de mode comme tom
ford vous ne seriez pas contre le fait
jean paul d'habiller mélanie un tram je
vais vous dire franchement je trouve que
c'est un peu absurde nord en quête de
quel droit je dirais mettons à cannes ne
pas venir dans ma boutique oui non si
elle veut venir et où qu elle vienne et
bien sûr et du fasciste de dire vous ne
pouvez pas vous pourquoi fait maintenant
je les remettrai quand même un bon show
un sombrero mexicain the
horse débit et katy perry pour la soirée
post oscars de mammifères mais là la
robe à craquer
ah oui bah non mais c'est sur les
petites ouvertures et des petites
surprises comme ça qu'ils arrivèrent à
science exactement c'est comme un
endroit en plus fabriqué jean-paul des
soutiens gorge conique pour les familles
et amis des jupes à des hommes est ce
que vous seriez prêt jean paul gaultier
à mettre des chaussettes rouges a beau
mannequin ou est ce que pour vous ce
serait tout match
bah ça dépend avec quoi oui ça oui il
n'ya rien de mal à cela vous pensez quoi
de ce que arnys fait pour françois
fillon bon c'est pas très excitant quoi
bon ouais vous savez je vais vous dire
une chose le ce qui est important c'est
la personne qui porte les vêtements mais
c'est elle qui rend à marseille les
vêtements
ouais c'est vrai que
la baisse forestière d'art mise quand
même ce serait bien avec un un kilt en
velours et un perfecto nos bas je crois
que je vous dis relate ce qui me choque
surtout c'est la façon il se tient un
petit peu comme ça ouais alors du coup
c'est vrai qu'il n'annonce pas pour
regarder par exemple les personnes qui
sont là se tiennent bien droite voilà
voilà voilà voilà alors que la salle
dans l'attitude ça compte est celle
gestes en fin de compte qui conte il est
un peu comme ça les emmerde et où il est
pas bien tu as raison
alors dernière fois que j'ai vu
l'émission the proxy en train de
préparer votre revue pour le
friedrichstadtpalast à berlin emma c'est
vrai on a les images et c'est juste
magnifique
[Musique]
quel talent c'est une belle aventure en
tous les cas le talent et votre revue
aux folies bergères alors c'est un
projet ça serait pour l'année prochaine
c'est vachement bien parce que comme
vous avez connaissez mon rêve enfin
renvoyant les folies bergère à la télé
c'est exactement donner envie d'être ce
que vous êtes ouais voilà alors jean
paul c'est ici ce soir parce que vous
signez à la monnaie de paris une série
de pièces de 10 euros et 2,50 euros
baptisé la france par jean paul gaultier
quand on vous a proposé l'idée vous
étiez sceptiques depuis vous avez
rencontré joachim le graveur en chef de
la monnaie de paris c'était formidable
parce que c'était vraiment une rencontre
c'est à dire que je me suis rendu compte
tout de suite qu'ils savaient comment
concrétiser en fin de compte les idées
mais je me disais avec une pièce de
monnaie quand même c'est assez plat
c'est petit qu'est-ce qu'on peut rendre
et en fin de compte tous les volumes et
toul sa belle elle est recréé je lui
montrer des photos des croquis plein de
choses et en plus le thème j'avais la
liberté pour choisir quoi faire on va
regarder moi ce que je pense qu'il ya un
truc extraordinaire c'est que ces
classiques serre que ce ce principe de
bas relief en fait et très années 30 on
va tout faire des co quelque part mais
avec l'inspiration gauthier évidemment
qui est pas du tout années trente ans on
regarde
[Musique]
jean paul gaultier vous dites au sujet
de sexualité
adolescent j'ai eu quelques aventures
avec des filles mais je ne savais pas
trop bas j'étais hésitant quand je me
suis dit que j'avais vu roméo et
juliette par exemple au cinéma et j'ai
fait rêver des deux bennes donc voilà
mais quand il est devenu évident vous
étiez homosexuels vous l'avez vécu très
naturellement que j'ai eu de la chance
d'avoir des parents qui était assez
ouvert et une grand-mère aussi qu'ils
étaient très ouverts d'esprit que aussi
parce que j'ai travaillé dans la mode et
il ya des réputations
léché cardin donc lui d'ailleurs été
pierre cardin ouais mais donc si vous
voulez et s'était ouvert dans ce milieu
donc du coup je suis jamais c'est pas un
problème d'ailleurs vous avez présenté
votre compagnon francis menuge à vos
parents que vous ont dit si vous êtes
heureux comme ça les enfants ce lundi
après d'abord la première fois où ça
s'était passé si j'avais vu un film avec
sidney pâtit peu près moitié de
l'héroïne qui vient dîner ce soir
exactement et ce film là et à la fin je
vais demander à mes parents et si moi
j'arrivais avec une fille ça c'était à
l'âge de 13 14 ans qui est black qu'est
ce que vous direz et m'ont dit très bien
et on si vous aimez c'est parfait c'est
même chose après quand j'ai apporté mon
compagnon amène avec blake va rien
changer
oui
cette musique pour moi c'est toi
vous
c'est à musique de jean paul
[Musique]
jean-paul maintenant vous ne serez pas
étonné qu'on fasse une interview foot de
goût
[Musique]
mais
alors que vous êtes déjà retrouvé un
dimanche matin en survêt et mocassins en
train de faire des courses
peut-être pas avec les mocassins mais en
survol truies à huy jean paul gaultier
mais disparaît mais ceci dit j'aime bien
l'idée de mélanger comment les mocassins
c'est bien pour les filles
c'est moi qui
évidemment est ce que vous êtes déjà
allé chercher du pain en peignoir en
pyjama en pyjama ouais est ce que vous
vous êtes déjà retrouvé en mars elle
devant un match de foot je ne regarde
pas le foot et en [ __ ] devant
marseille
est ce que vous mettez des chaussettes
avec des nu pieds ça j'aime bien le côté
un peu touristes allemands c'est par les
ceintures est ce que vous mettez des
chaussettes blanches avec des chaussures
noires bien bien bien ah oui c'est
pareil pour la femme avec des bas blancs
et les contrastes comme ça et tout
soutien gorge noir sous quelque chose
d'une chemise blanche l'avait cédée
conseils pour toutes nos ennemis est ce
que vous mettez des chemises à manches
courtes
hawaïenne hawaïenne ouais vous porter
des chemises ah ouais j'aime bien
l'imprimé hawaïen est ce que vous mettez
parfois des rayures et des pois ensemble
superbe ah oui on mélange de pois aussi
ensemble à wayne on les mélange de
j'aime bien pris mais il n'est pas pour
moi là je dis ça en tant que mode
peut-être que pour moi je suis un peu
plus haut on va dire mais sinon j'adore
pour les pour les autres les mélange de
pois d'apprêter
[Musique]
sacré en se voyant aucun jeu wii un jeu
très facile pour jean-paul je vais vous
montrer des photos il faut trouver le
créateur très bien bah c'est assez
facile on commence avec la première
photo jean paul gaultier non ray-ban
y porter ray-ban
homme fort en oeuvre de bach à 9 2 à 9
de pâques pas si l'alsace et paco
rabanne mais ça n'a pas tellement marché
mais c'est très mauvais très mauvais
très mauvais on va occuper le mauvais
mais alors adolphe attend galliano
galliano roi ou un point
[Applaudissements]
pacy fullana f1 cr fe soit là tu as bien
aux bus à bosser pointois
pense que je faisais le jeu de mots
comme alors sauf audace est une femme
qui a repris le travail de son frère qui
s'est fait assassiner bienséance et
donatella versace
on me dit qu'on n'est pas sûr de la
photo
[Applaudissements]
est morte une baisse assez dior
c'est dior homme
et quand on regarde ça dans un miroir ça
fait hémorroïdes
très facile
la plus célèbre de toute chapelle
chanel peuple coco chanel
coco well as voit jamais
ouais bien gars
donc non ça c'est les boucheries bernard
c'est une erreur
et on termine avec
thierry la maison du deuil bien sûr
bravo
incroyable
et maintenant mesdames messieurs en
hommage à juliette binoche on va faire
un blindtest l'ofs
[Musique]
je veux l'interprète laurent je t'en
supplie bas je me tais non tu as ton
d'égal voilà tu décris des prêts à
l'emploi des cadres d'environ 20 minutes
il
les beatles mois
[Musique]
là
d
genre
là la vision d'un fouet attention
musique
[Musique]
lyon c'est jean paul gaultier
je propose que pour la troisième chanson
on attende un peu jusqu'à ce qu'elle
trouve tu vas trouver un sens c'est bien
que tu vas trouver tu vas suis sûr mais
oui
à
moi
musique
ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
il a tout pompé sur obispo
music &
whitney houston et houston
dégueulasse
dans les églises tout ça
ça à montaigu
à tomber navale cin montaigu et capulet
compris à l'intérieur ça marche fort
logique
[Musique]
et ouais ouais ouais quand même
attention musique
[Musique]
honneur de me
démerder
c'est à vous
mon pc
demain summer produite par diomandé
évidemment démissionner oui ouais ouais
je vais très bien très bien très bravo
laurent attention musique
[Musique]
non
alors
[Applaudissements]
logique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michael jackson beau
alors que
bon maintenant celui qui trouve ça a
tout gagné ever c'est super dur c'est
une chanson qui a été reprise par
michael jackson et justin timberlake
mais ça c'est la version originale
musique
et
je ne sais pas
je johnny mathis non johnny mathis
[Applaudissements]
l'argent pas là
ou là respect absolu et maintenant
mesdames messieurs on passe au bilan de
l'émission
[Musique]
c'est le bilan alors arrêt habitants est
ce qu'il ya des choses que vous
regrettez d'avoir dit dans cette
émission fait le bilan de l'émission
franchement je passe un très bon moment
je ne regrette jamais ce que je dis en
général bon j'essaye toujours d'être le
plus simple possible le plus authentique
possible mes chers concitoyens mais
cheikh votre pilote nous arrivons en
tête 30 jours donc la présence et de mes
chers amis je ne dirai qu'une chose vive
la france et vive la république
jean paul est ce qu'il ya des choses que
vous regrettez d'avoir dit des choses
que vous regrettez de ne pas avoir dit
absolument pas si j'ai passé un très bon
moment très bonne compagnie en plus j'ai
gagné le super bonus
tout à gagner de la mitad et me voilà
juliette
après réflexion je me dis qu'en brasser
des chaussettes 100 fois celle
où j'en suis pas encore revenu
voilà c'était le bilan
[Musique]
ewen on le sait était de bilan
post le bilan alors qu'istres est
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
colling
ouais ouais bon choix listeria club
bonsoir détail tous enfin toujours en
courbe en u 2 juillet
jean paul gaultier
les habitants
des landes la vie et maintenant c'est
l'heure de grille en 2017
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
don mais bon
on commence avec la démission de bruno
le roux qui a employé ses deux filles
pendant les vacances d'été comme
collaboratrice parlementaire
démission démarrait alors qu'elle était
âgée de 15 ans coût pour le contribuable
55000 euros en six ans ça doit être
chouette d'être les enfants brûlent
euros les filles vous voulez bosser à
l'assemblée cet été il ya dix mille
euros à vous partager ça peut être sympa
en plus sur un plein de jeunes de votre
âge bas tous les enfants des députés les
petits balkany les petits cahuzac c'est
cool pouvez profiter du restaurant du
bas faire la fête dans l'hémicycle c'est
comme une colo mais vous êtes payé 1
c'est ça vous partez en ardèche avec
nous vous choisissez
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien parce que les socialistes ne
sont jamais à la traîne du voyage ici
cela vaut les autres c'est un plaisir
la réalité du travail des filles de
bruno l'euro et elle avérée en 2013
l'aîné a effectué une mission alors
qu'elle était en stage au même moment
chez yves rocher en belgique mais ça ça
c'est différent c'était pour avoir des
crèmes des soins gratos yves rocher tout
ce qui est réduction bouton élimination
de point noir c'est le meilleur à 15 ans
il pourrait d'acné de complexe un stage
chez yves rocher ça se refuse pas
la perle de la semaine est attribué une
fois de plus à jean christophe
cambadélis pour sa phrase je ne vois pas
pourquoi bruno le roux devrait
démissionner il n'est pas candidat à la
présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
bon
quand tu t'appelles leroux est défendue
par un mec qu'on comme une blonde
le secret du club des hollandais enfin
révéler tous les lundis soir stéphane le
foll réunis dans son ministère une
poignée d'irréductibles rester fidèle à
françois hollande d'après le député
gilles savary ce club très fermé et
réservé aux purs et au tattoo et
[Musique]
bonsoir des fidèles à françois du
conflit macron du mecsek rebelle tué
hamon qui vomit les fronts 2 c'est fait
tu as tu épuré tatoué mot de passe les
folles c'est bon offre
[Applaudissements]
une biographie sur florian philippot
nous apprend que le bras droit de marine
le pen y possède un appartement à saint
germain des prés quasi villes à
l'intérieur un lit un bureau une chaise
et une photo dédicacée de dorothée
il devrait essayer d'entrer au club des
hollandais philippot devenir membre
bonsoir je déteste hollande tué au front
national tuéni pure ni tatoué mais tu as
une photo de dorothée dédicaces et c'est
bon or le faux les tombes a dit attends
[Applaudissements]
emmanuel macron assure avoir trouvé des
convergences avec merkel macro et
trouvent des convergences avec tout le
monde de robert hue alain madelin ça
pourrait devenir une couleur le
maquereau vois un truc qui va avec tout
ça je sais pas quoi mettre dans la
cuisine ja du bordeaux du verre du
orange mais du maquereau le maquereau tu
peux pas te tromper ça va avec tout ou
un plat ça pourrait devenir un plat le
maquereau à je sais pas je sais pas quoi
manger je suis ballonné j'ai envie de
rien prend du maquereau ça va avec tout
sucré salé viandes poissons plats en
sauce ça n'a aucun goût mais ça passe
tout seul
pour henri guaino emmanuel macron c'est
le candidat des dîners en ville basse au
t1 10 nec macron c'est forcément la
classe c comme les soirées de
l'ambassadeur avec les chocolats ferrero
rocher c'est toujours un succès
les réceptions des manuels macron sont
réputés pour le bon goût du maître de
maison un goût raffiné qui charme
toujours les invités droite et gauche
réunies anciens communistes ou anciens
d'occident emmanuel macron charme tous
les esprits
emmanuel macron excellent
l' enquête sur françois fillon élargie à
des faits de faux et usage de faux et
d'escroquerie aggravée on s'en fout on
s'en fout on s'en fout quoi qu'il fasse
maintenant il peut faire comme robert
rochefort le député du modem montrait sa
[ __ ] dans un castorama
[Applaudissements]
pierre moscovici s'est fait offrir des
costumes de luxe chez le même tailleur
que françois fillon
ça doit être sympa en ce moment
l'ambiance chez arnys
à monsieur moscovici vous venez chercher
vos affaires s'est payé un tout est
réglé alors on a deux costumes trois
chemises katravas tenda barbier voilà je
vérifie dans le fichier clients
balkanique zac
fillon leroux moscovici ça y est vous y
retrouver la dcri paye en liquide on
peut pas se servir de l'informatique
donc ça complique je vous offre les
housses c'est normal chez arnys le
client est roi roy président ou
dictateurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
indiqué
qu' à l'époque mais vaut mieux en rire
qu'en pleurer comme disait l'autre bon
marché beaumarchais nicolas dupont
aignan quitte le jt de tf1 pour
protester contre son absence au grand
débat organisé par tf1
donc invité sur tf1 dupont aignan qui
tf1 car il est furieux de ne pas être
conviés sur tf1
c'est une campagne faut suivre quand
même
[Applaudissements]
en prison on s'en tape alain plateau qui
est si bien tenu que ce mail a enfin
thierry comme elle c'est incroyable
frosch mais franchement quel manque de
goût oui moi je serais pas parti
ouais c'est une vanne pour les initiés
télévision succès d'audience pour
mélissa theuriau et sa nouvelle émission
candidats au tableau le concept les
enfants d'une école primaire interroge
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
moi j'ai été un peu déçu par les
questions posées à françois fillon ouais
non je m'attendais à plus de candeur
d'innocence de la part des enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour si vous monsieur fillon pourquoi
tu es un menteur pourquoi tu as dit
qu'il démissionnerait s'il était mis en
examen est finalement un tueur est
question suivante
suffit ou mon papa m'a offert une robe
de princesse pour noël est ce que tu
penses qu'un jour je devrais la lui
rembourser comme tu as fais toi avec ta
fille pour sa robe de mariée est ce que
tous les papas sont aussi cruel que toi
question suivante sur fion est ce que
nos pères et qu'on bat compères n'est
pas con pourquoi tu dis ça mon petit
bonhomme parce que toute l'année il
travaille super dur à l'usiné à la fin
du mois quand il a payé toutes les
factures il a même pas de quoi s'acheter
un pantalon à la halle aux vêtements
alors que toi il ya quelqu'un qui
t'offre des super costumes à 9000 euros
donc je me disais est ce que mon père
est con
question suivante
tu viennes je déteste l'école j'aime que
m'amuser et jouer avec les copains du
coup mon rêve c'est de faire comme
pénélope chez beaucoup d'argent ce rien
faire c'est quoi son secret décidément
la vérité sort toujours de la bouche des
enfants
[Applaudissements]
benoît hamon s'en prend à laurent
wauquiez fervent défenseur de la clause
molière tartuffe wauquiez s'est il
insurgé fabrice luchini grands
spécialistes de molière n'aurait pas dit
le contraire
évidemment wauquiez c'est un tartuffe
faites ce que je dis pas ce que je fais
l'archétype du faux jeton défenseur de
la manif pour tous et dans le même temps
et fréquente les soirées gay le cul
entre deux chaises lavaud qui
fervent catholique femmes de se ré
manuel et parallèlement imad des pornos
sur youporn
après ses meetings seul dans sa chambre
mercure imagine dans sa parka rouge
tirant sur le [ __ ]
pour être des veaux
je n'en suis pas moins homme
wauquiez qui refusent d'accueillir les
migrants dans sa région même le pape
françois s'est indigné c'est énorme
le faux jeton dans toute sa splendeur
couvrez ce sein que je ne saurais voir
par de pareilles objets les hameçons de
l'essai et cela fait venir deux
coupables penser mais j'irai dès ce soir
à l'abri des regards dans un hôtel
mercure me tirait sur l'audace
wauquiez
tartuffe et les précieuses ridicules
réunis dans le même sac l'engeance
l'immonde laurent wauquiez la crapule
c'est ainsi
les piscines à cheval de troie à
et maintenant on passe à notre terriens
du sable
[Musique]
nicolas frize bonsoir bonsoir
nicolas vous avez la capacité de sortir
de votre corps pour aller explorer
d'autres lieux comme si votre conscience
qu'on pouvait se déplacer tout seul ça
s'appelle la des corporations out of
body eksperyans au but i see vide et
aulas bonsoir
vous êtes docteur en biologie
moléculaire
à l'université de genève et vous étudiez
le cadre de nicolas depuis dix ans et
ensemble vous publié aux éditions guy
trédaniel un livre qui s'appelle voyage
aux confins de la conscience
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nicolas vous êtes né le 5
septembre 1982 à romans-sur-isère dans
la drôme
votre père employé municipal
votre mère infirmière tout à fait comme
beaucoup d'enfants vous avez une grande
capacité à vous extraire du réel quand
vous vous ennuyez mais bientôt vous
constatez que c'est de votre corps et
non pas du réel que vous pouvez vous
extraire votre grand mère a des
aptitudes similaire quand elle vous
envoie chercher du pain à la boulangerie
elle vous précise qui reste deux
couronnes dont une qui est trop cuite
est une qui est bien dorée et en
arrivant dans la boulangerie vous
constatez que c'est vrai c'est ça mais
pour moi c'était normal je me posais pas
la question de savoir si elle avait
quelque chose de particulier par rapport
à d'autres alors vous avez sept ans
quand vous avez conscience que vous
pouvez quitter la salle de classe et que
vous pouvez vous retrouver chez vous
avec vos chiens
oui c'est vrai
je me suis rendu compte que c'était pas
seulement des rêveries ouais en fait oui
c'est pas des moments d'absence ou des
rêveries non mais vraiment vous extraire
de votre corps est allé chez vous voilà
c'est ça et voir à l'instant t ce qui
s'y passe alors pendant ces moments là
les gens qui vous entourent crois que
vous êtes dans la lune en fait vous
sortez de votre corps mais colin dit
comme une vapeur comme une brume qui
s'en détachent oui c'est effectivement
ce type de sensations c'est comme si à
quelque chose de plus fluide que le
corps quelque chose de plus subtil se
décaler légèrement du corps vers l'avant
et à partir de ce moment là il ya sortes
d'effets de balancement de tourbillon et
je me retrouve dans l'endroit où mon
corps ne se trouve pas ouais à l'époque
je vécus vous semble avoue tout à fait
normal complètement complètement pour
moi tout le monde pouvait le faire mes
copains de classe je pensais qu'il
pouvait le faire aussi
c'était logique car on se trouver un
endroit où on se faisait chier eh ben on
pouvait aller dans un autre c'était
logique à leurs rêves et bientôt vous
réalisez effectivement en discutant avec
vos copains qu'ils ne vivent pas du tout
la même chose que vous vous en parlez à
votre prof de maths qui vous conseille
d'en parler à votre médecin
à la maison le sujet est tabou un veau
paris on n'a pas parlé jusqu'à jusqu'à
ce que mon cas soit effectivement étudié
par des scientifiques aux parents ils
pensent que c'est des fadaises tout ça
enfin ils pensaient à l'époque
évidemment alors vous même vous commencé
à douter mais un jour alors que vous
ennuyer au fond de la classe vous vous
retrouvez chez vous et vous voyez votre
père construire un petit muret et le
soir quand vous rentrez de l'école vous
vérifiez que votre père a effectivement
construit se met petit muret c'est vrai
et ça ça a été on va dire une des
nombreuses vérifications que j'ai fait
tout au long de mon enfance pour vous
dire je ne suis pas fou à l'âge de
saison grâce à ce don un peu bizarre
vous commencez à jouir d'une petite
notoriété et vos copains vous dise
d'avoir ce cas au menu de la cantine oui
je suis devenu un petit peu le l'espion
qui permet d'avoir des informations en
fait vous apprenez à tirer partie de vos
des corporations par exemple quand vous
avez un examen ou laisser un livre
ouvert chez vous et vous allez voir ce
qu'il ya effectivement et voilà donc ça
je les fait de nombreuses fois ouais
j'ai pareil quand vous n'avez pas de
ticket dans le tramway vous projetez à
la station suivante vous voyez celle où
il n'ya pas de contrôleur et vous vous
arrêtez à celle là et je vais à pied
vérifié à la station suivante pour être
sûr qu'il y avait effectivement voilà
c'est pareil pour à lyon c'est pas les
vélib c'est les vélo'v pareil donc pour
savoir s'il ya une place devait leur
combat
et avec les filles moi c'est pas
vraiment les films mais bon après
alors
après des études de comptabilité
vous trouvez un job dans un grand groupe
et ce qui est marrant c'est que ça vous
sert aussi dans le boulot parce que
quand vous êtes en vacances vous
retournez à votre bureau et vous voyez
au sommet de la pile de courrier une
lettre urgente une aide très importante
donc vous le signaler à votre
collaboratrice qui fallait la traiter en
urgence parfois il ya des choses qu'on
n'a pas envie de voir par exemple oui
s'il ya certaines choses qu'on est
forcément on n'a pas envie de voir par
exemple ou par exemple ça m'est arrivé
de surprendre mon ex-compagnon
en compagnie de quelqu'un il sortait de
son corps aussi
les 17 juillet 2006 suivi vous
rencontrer nicolas pour la première fois
il est en congé à martigues chez la mère
de son compagnon et vous vous participer
à un colloque consacré à l'avenir def
xpérience la n 2 e voilà moi ce jour là
j'étais en train de monter avec mon
collègue coacher un foyer un projet de
recherche sur ces phénomènes ça faisait
déjà à peu près 10 ans ont recueilli des
témoignages de ce type on avait déjà des
centaines de témoignages mais voilà le
mois en tant que scientifique c'est vrai
que j'avais quand même se doute venir
c'est quand même assez incroyable
d'imaginer que la conscience puisse
faire ce genre de choses donc je voulais
monter un projet scientifique pour
vérifier la réalité des deux ce qui
rapportait savoir si c'était une
hallucination bien si on avait affaire à
quelque chose d'autre et voilà comment
vous vous retrouvez nicolas 24 ans au
laboratoire de recherche de l'université
de genève là vous racontez vos sorties
du corps alors en fait c'est un
mouvement vers l'avant de la totalité du
corps et vous vous retrouvez
instantanément
ailleurs en train d'observer une scène
csii alors vous voyez pas dans ces cas
là les choses d'un point de vue
extérieur
vous êtes toute la scène que vous
observez c'est pas un regard comme ça si
vous êtes partie de ses gains c'est ça
la totalité à la fois ci je si par
exemple je me projetais ici je serai à
la fois votre bureau le sol tout ce qui
nous entoure mais aussi vous vous les
pensées toutes les informations en fait
qu'ils sont présenterait il ya plus
qu'une vision c'est une communion oui
c'est ça serait plus s'asseoir et de ses
seins alors au retour quand vous revenez
dans votre corps un vous ressentez comme
une forme de compression comme si on
voulait faire entrer quelque chose d'un
peu
gros dans quelque chose de petit 1 c'est
ça c'est ça en fait c'est vraiment cette
idée de faire rentrer quelque chose d'un
fini dans une toute petite boîte ouais
en fait vous ne pouvez pas partir en des
corporations con ça vous chante il faut
quand même que vous soyez détendu et que
vous ressentiez un besoin d'y aller on
va dire que la sortie se fait assez
facilement lorsque je m'ennuie après
c'est la destination dans laquelle deux
je vais je vais me retrouver il faut
qu'il y ait effectivement quelque chose
de prenant je dirais émotionnellement
parlant pour que je me trouve à
l'endroit voulu et quand vous sortez de
votre corps votre enveloppe corporelle
on peut vous parler vous êtes ailleurs
vous pouvez parler moche ailleurs donc
vous pouvez toujours par il vous
répondez vous n'aurez pas du tout en
fait c'est lorsqu'une ya des
corporations mon corps restent
totalement figée maintenant avoir un
magnéto qui prouve exactement ce que
vous racontez c'est une expérience dont
qui a été fait on vous demande d'aller
dans une boulangerie pour voir ce qui se
passe dans cette boulangerie au
[Musique]
niveau de l'entrée du
laboratoire de cuisine avec avec le
floor le four à pain il y avait en
travers du passage une caisse jaune
ap un qui devait être un truc comme ça
mais couché sur le sur le côté avec
enfin pas vraiment totalement par terre
il y avait une espèce de son blanc
peut-être quelque chose de blanc en
dessous hormis ce à quoi dire d'autre il
y avait la vendeuse qui étaient là que
je connais donc est ce que c'est une
vision à distance ou est ce que c'est
quelque chose que dont je me souviens je
ne sais pas tout ce que je sais c'est
que l avis
une grosse boucle d'oreille comme un
bouton mais avec une vraie
avec une ancre de bateau
vous voyez à distance
bouquets sont fx le terrible il est
hallucinant
aujourd'hui c'est un candidat on va pas
dire cobayes parce qu'on n'aime pas ça
mais c'est un candidat fantastique c'est
à partir de là sylvie vous mener de
nombreuses expériences scientifiques
avec nicolas il ya la photo de la tour
eiffel ce qui est très étonnant racontez
nous parce que en fait ils voient ils
voient la tour eiffel mais il n'arrive
pas à dire que c'est naturel falcon
c'est un des premiers tests qu'on a fait
avec lui tout au début on le connaissait
à peine on faisait une projection
d'image derrière un écran et revient en
disant j'ai vu quelque chose c'était
pointu
un peu comme un avec une barre
transversale il ya des il ya des
croisillons je dirais que c'était au
métal mais je vois absolument pas ce que
c'est
et à aucun moment il a été capable
d'interpréter ce qu'ils voyaient pas
c'est la tour eiffel mais il décrit la
tour f tout a faim il ya aussi la
télépathie alors ça c'est incroyable la
lys et l'avenir de vos expériences c'est
à dire que là vous pouvez écouter les
ponts c'est qu'on a oui c'est ça m'est
possible sam est possible de
d'entendre entre guillemets le flot de
penser que vous que vous avez enfin que
chacun d'entre nous a constamment là par
exemple ce que vous voyez que l'émission
est bientôt terminée j'ai envie d'aller
fumer un pétard
alors là des corporations donc et la
télépathie nous permettre d'être
imbattable poker effectivement
effectivement mais j'utilise passer ses
capacités en dehors du cercle amical
c'est du cercle sur le sussex
scientifiques tout ça nous ramène au
poids de l'âme l'être humain perd 21
grammes au moment de sa mort c'est
quelque chose qui a été démontré dans
les années 1900 par le docteur dang
khanh macdougall il ya eu un film qui a
été fait et qui s'appelle 21 grams
effectivement alors vous ce qu'est très
spécial c'est que quand vous vous des
corpore vous perdez 45 g est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il existe des âmes plus
lourde que d'autres il ya eu il ya eu
effectivement une
une expérience avec avec une balance de
précision
qui a démontré une perte puis
récupération de quarante et quelques
grammes mais c'est une réputation une
expérience qu'on a réussi à faire qu'une
seule fois donc pour l'instant c'est
assez préliminaire on peut pas vraiment
en tirer des conclusions mais
effectivement la seule fois où il a
réussi à faire une une sortie hors du
corps alors qu'il était sur cette
balance il ya eu cette différence de
poids étonnante alors en 2009 nicolas
vous vous retrouvez perdu dans le cosmos
là c'est grave parce que vous êtes pu
achever boulangerie 1 vous êtes dans le
cosmos et vous vous retrouvez un moment
en face du l'énorme masse lumineuse
dites-vous un nuage d'une blancheur pure
et là vous communiquez avec cette masse
lumineuse et vous entendez respect
respect disons que
entendre c'est un bien grand mot mais
disons que j'ai capté ça oui je suis
quand je suis revenu il ya eu ce
ce terme qui s'est imposée à moi
pourquoi jean ça y est je pense que je
préfère ne pas me poser ses 50 ans un
moment hier à l'époque quand vous avez
vécu ça vous pensez que vous êtes devenu
fou un moment parce que c'est vrai qu'on
forme vraiment une fois voir le mental
d' de supporter ce genre d'expérience ce
qui est extraordinaire aussi c'est que
il vous arrive de vous retrouver dans le
corps d'un autre un moment elle se
retrouve dans le corps d'un mec qui
s'appelle robert qui fait l'amour à sa
femme vous vous captez au moose
maître-chien ouais ouais c'était en
effet passé
comment ça s'est passé en fait chaque
soir avant de m'endormir je fais une
sortie de corps qui se passe depuis 2009
dans le cosmos et puis un jour au lieu
de me retrouver là haut je me suis
retrouvé dans le corps de quelqu'un dans
ce corps qui étaient plutôt comment
dirais-je généreux pour pas dire autre
chose devant un match de foot et
navettes obligé de regarder le foot et
voilà taper fort que c'est pas trop mon
truc
voilà et je me suis retrouvé chaque soir
dans sept personnes 1 et ad on va dire
dans des situations plus ou moins
intimes ce cadre scabreuses alors il
vous arrive de vous retrouver dans le
corps d'animaux dans le corps de biche
oui entre autres comment c'est d'être
dans un corps de biche c'est musclé
c'est doux c'est
[Musique]
saglam agréable dans le corps de ce
félin très agréable aussi dans le corps
d'oiseau ce qu'est la meilleure
expérience vraiment parce que oui mais
le problème est entre guillemets c'est
que dans le corps d'un oiseau c'est j'ai
eu peur de ne pas savoir voler parce que
sur le moment je reste je reste moi même
j'ai toujours cette plus ou moins cette
façon de penser alors voilà donc là
maintenant on est au coeur du sujet si
vie c'est à dire que la conscience
semble pouvoir se trouver aussi bien à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur du cerveau
le cerveau en fait ne serait qu'un
récepteur qu'un réceptacle d'une
conscience omniprésente
est-ce que c'est vers ça que vos travaux
vous amène de plus en plus on n'a pas
encore la preuve formelle parce qu'avec
les recherches qu'on a fait avec nicolas
on a pu me prouver que l'on n'avait pas
on n'était pas en phase d'hallucinations
qui se passait vraiment quelque chose
mais on n'a pas pu démontrer que sa
conscience vraiment se délocalisait mais
disons que l'ensemble de tous les
témoignages et de tous les travaux qui
sont faits dans dans ce domaine vont
dans ce sens qui anime une idée assez
révolutionnaire puisque c'est ça va à
l'encontre du on pourrait dire du dogme
actuel des neurosciences qui postule que
la conscience est une sorte de de
sécrétion de l'activité cérébrale oui
sauf que depuis l'antiquité depuis les
égyptiens on parle dames
les indiens parlent dames les chrétiens
parlent dame nicolas vous avez déclaré
je vois désormais le monde comme une des
infinis projection de la conscience vous
faire une confidence quand j'ai pris de
la cide j'avais que des pixels et ses
pixels je pouvais les organiser dans
toutes les images que je voulais c'est
pixels c'était moi qui décide et de les
organiser c'est un petit peu la même
chose en fait c'est à dire que vous êtes
au coeur d'une conscience
omni présente
qui intègre tour c'est ça
c'est vraiment l'idée c'est que toutes
aient conscience et la matière n'est
qu'une projection de la conscience alors
il ya un évêque anglais du xviième
siècle s'appelait berkeley qui disait
exactement ça c'est à dire que c'est la
conscience qui prédomine est que le
monde n'est qu'une des formes qu'on
donne à la confiance ça qui est
intéressant actuellement c'est qu'il ya
des chercheurs de différents domaines
aussi bien en physique en biologie et en
médecine qui s'achemine vers cette idée
que peut-être là le substrat même de
l'univers en fait à l'origine de tout il
y aurait la conscience et que la matière
serait une sorte de cristallisation de
la conscience si on peut dire donc c'est
un renversement total de perdre complet
et c'est fascinant c'est passionnant
vous êtes content d'avoir ce dont je
suis content d'avoir cette cette
capacité vous êtes cette facilité est
également d'avis on l'a tous
après c'est à mon avis comme en musique
il ya des personnes qui sont qui ont
plus de facilité que d'autres
si demain je venais à ne plus avoir
cette capacité c'est exactement comme si
on m'a arraché les deux yeux
parce que c'est devenu un sens
même titre que la jupe ou que le toucher
merci en tous les cas nicolas nancy
chimie merci les violets en parler
[Musique]
je veux
sauf une
sans alcool
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'était saluent les talents votre
taux du samedi soir avec juliette
jean paul
kane
nom me rends
harry
merci à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé alors
sept ans
nous souhaitons prochain à 19h et d'ici
là c'est du point fr au revoir
l'émission
salutaire
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu